just so you guys know you do need 47
construction or the glory amount that I
will be using in this if you don't know
how to do that look it up I'm sure
there's a guide online how to do a
blurry amount and then you also need 50
construction to use the demon Butler I'm
going to use but you can use any Butler
but I was already have 47 construction
for that for the glory mount so I
decided to go ahead and get 250 it
should only take if you're a 1
construction this method literally it'll
take maybe an hour to get to do
construction it takes literally is so
quick to do construction I highly
recommend doing it alright let's get
started into the video what is up guys
I'm here with another money-making guide
and today we're gonna be making mahogany
planks so all you need is mahogany logs
coins and some la runes and also get the
dust battle staff so you can teleport to
your house so it already has the built
in routes for you and all you need is a
lot of room so go ahead and start by
teleporting to your house and then run
to where your glory mountain is
I just put this in so it kind of takes
me while we get used to it but I will
show you how to do an efficient run
after this so go ahead and call your
servant
you do need a serving bowl to do it
this is my first time doing this but I
had I figured it out you have to go to
click to the sawmill and then go ahead
and click it again tell them to go to
the Somme know because you he wants you
to give him the log so you have to go
ahead and hand them over the logs so you
use your mahogany log on the butler and
then he'll take them to the sawmill he
will charge 39 K per run go ahead and
put in a random number so he takes them
all and then he will go for 39 thousand
and then go ahead and teleport to
Edgeville
and then you will run to the bank
and I will time this and let's see how
long it takes to make 500
okay so this is how you do an efficient
run so go ahead and take out your
mahogany logs teleport to your house run
mount is call your servant as you're
running there
click one space one space teleport
and then go to your house I mean go to
your bank alright so I finished my five
hundred mahogany logs making them into
planks it took seven minutes and 50
seconds so about eight minutes so now I
will go ahead and go to the grand
exchange and I will sell them so before
I could sell them I had to do some math
so real quick the ten thousand the first
time it cost me to pay the butler eight
trips and the other ten thousand cost me
so twenty thousand plus the two hundred
eighty six thousand of the logs plus all
the long runs I used and plus the amount
of times I had to pay the butler which
is like nineteen point two times times
thirty nine thousand all right and now
we will sell them we will go ahead and
sell them so they sell instantly 2,200
that should sell instantly and it does
so let's write down how much I spent 1
million fifty nine thousand four hundred
sixty and now we will do what I made
- what I paid so
you
so sixty divided by eight minutes that
it took times the 65 thousand five
hundred forty four hundred ninety-one so
if you did this hourly it'd be 500 K I
know I didn't do it for an hour but it
is now really method I promise
stay tuned for my next video guys thanks
for watching